verzweifelt das pflegepersonal mahnende
wissenschaftler müde eltern alle warten
auf klare entscheidungen in sachen
corona wo die vierte welle endlich zu
stoppen und brauchen doch noch geduld am
donnerstag da soll es dann wieder nach
dem gespräch heute eine
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz geben es
ist jetzt schon klar es wird stärkere
kontakt beschränkungen für ungeimpfte
geben großveranstaltungen sollen
möglichst abgesagt werden bis
weihnachten will man 30 millionen
impfdosen verabreichen und eine
impfpflicht die rückt auch näher die
ausgangssperren im vergangenen jahr die
waren zulässig das hat heute das
bundesverfassungsgericht entschieden und
derweil ist die neue virusvariante
omikron auch in deutschland angekommen
neue mutation neue sorgen wie kriegen
wir corona in den griff unser thema
heute in der phoenix runde
[Musik]
phoenix runde
schönen guten abend ganz herzlich
willkommen aus berlin ich darf meine
gäste vorstellen hier im studio ist
miriam hollstein chefreporterin politik
in der funk und medien gruppe herzlich
willkommen bei uns jetzt professor timm
ulrichs
epidemiologe der akad hochschule für
humanwissenschaften und hat unter
anderem auch in südafrika mal studiert
und sich mit der tuberkulose beschäftigt
und dort in südafrika in johannesburg
ist uns richard klug zugeschaltet er als
korrespondent für das südliche afrika
dort hat man ja das neue die neue
mutation omikron entdeckt herzlich
willkommen aber ich hatte glück nach
johannesburg und ich begrüße ganz
herzlich stefan schaaf er ist ard
korrespondent für spanien portugal und
den maghreb wir schauen nach spanien
denn dort ist die impfquote viel höher
als in deutschland ganz ohne impfung
schönen abend in beiden beginnen wir mit
ihnen frau holstein wir haben eine bund
länder konferenz heute gehabt eine
telefonkonferenz die scheidende
kanzlerin und der designierte neue
kanzler waren dabei und alle hatten
gedacht jetzt muss doch endlich was
passieren es ist zeit haben alle so
stark gewandt und so einen richtig
offiziellen beschluss hat man nicht
bekommen und auch weder angela merkel
noch olaf scholz sind heute für die
presse getreten ist denn jetzt was
passiert es ist was passiert und ich
finde eine ganze menge nämlich zum einen
sie habe es in der einleitung erwähnt
dass das bundesverfassungsgericht ein
ganz klares signal gegeben hat in dem es
gesagt hat die maßnahmen die im rahmen
der bundes notbremse im frühjahr
getroffen wurden die waren zulässig
unter den damaligen bedingungen und zum
anderen dass bei dem heutigen treffen
was ja offiziell keine bund länder
konferenz oder keinen
ministerpräsidenten gipfel war dass olaf
scholz einen sehr weitreichenden plan
vorgelegt hat unter anderem indem er
indem er sagt dass eine allgemeine
impfpflicht kommen könnte und dass
dieser zweig regel ausgeweitet wird und
dass jetzt auch apotheker impfen sollen
dürfen und dass diese 30 millionen
impfungen bis weihnachten passieren
sollen und wenn das jetzt am donnerstag
dann auch festgeschrieben wird bei der
nun kurzfristig offiziell geplanten
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
dann sind wir immerhin schon mal einen
schritt weiter aber warum hat man das
heute nicht schon richtig festgelegt
warum ist man hat ja das gefühl von der
wissenschaft da wird wirklich gewarnt
schon seit die ganze letzte woche ist es
immer wir müssen endlich ganz schnell
etwas machen und jetzt sagt man auch
jetzt gucken wir erstmal und dann
treffen uns am donnerstag wieder und das
dauert dann doch lange
ja dann legen sie den finger in die
wunde denn man könnte sagen das sind
alles ganz wunderbare maßnahmen aber
eigentlich hätte man die schon vor einem
monat festlegen müssen das lka hat ja
schon im juli darauf hingewiesen dass
wir booster impfung insbesondere für
risikopatienten und für die älteren
vorbereiten müssen und auch die
impfdosen dafür vorhalten muss das ist
offenbar nicht passiert und man muss
natürlich jetzt sagen bei allen
maßnahmen die jetzt angekündigt werden
die große frage die ja im raum steht ist
brauchen wir ein lockdown ich glaube wir
brauchen ein und dass diese maßnahme
neben angesichts der jetzigen lage nicht
ausreichen werden fragen wir den
ethnologen herr ulrich reichen die
maßnahmen denn jetzt oder könnte das
ausreichen wir wissen noch nicht genau
was alles genau umgesetzt wird jedes
land schaut natürlich auch nach seiner
incident und was es dann was jedes land
für sich entscheiden muss also was wäre
jetzt ihrer meinung nach am wichtigsten
gewesen was man vielleicht auch heute
hätte entscheiden müssen ja also wie
schon gesagt also eigentlich hätte man
das alles viel viel früher schon
entscheiden müssen das ist ja eine ganz
wichtige erfahrung in der pandemie dass
man solche maßnahmen wenn man sie
einsetzt möglichst frühzeitig im einsatz
also noch am beginn einer welle und dann
auch möglichst hart also das heißt
umfassend und nicht immer nur so ein
bisschen halbherzige entscheidungen
werden immer sofort bestraft das haben
wir gesehen in der zweiten welle wo sich
das ja auch noch verzögert erst
abgespielt hat und jetzt haben wir eben
eine welle die ist so groß dass man also
da auch schon überlegt eben oder
überlegen könnte man hätte es eben alles
sehr viel früher machen können und um
ihre frage zu beantworten also ja solche
maßnahmen könnten helfen aber wir wissen
es dann immer erst in 14 tagen das heißt
also erst dann würden wir die effekte
sehen und diese zeit haben wir einfach
nicht deswegen würde auch hier
eigentlich die empfehlungen seien bis
hin zu einem harten lockdown leider
daneben für alle also auch für die
vollständig geimpften die sich immer gut
verhalten haben und alles richtig
gemacht haben aber wir kommen aus der
lage eigentlich nur wieder raus wenn wir
wirklich massive kontakt beschränkungen
jetzt schnell beschließen also was mit
was rechnen sie denn jetzt noch für die
nächsten 14 tagen haben wir immer im
verlauf wir hatten jetzt extrem hohe
infektionszahlen fiel höher aus als im
letzten winter also womit rechnen sie
jetzt für die nächsten 14 tage da es
wird jetzt noch weiter gehen also auch
wenn das morgen beschlossen oder
übermorgen geschlossen werden sollte es
muss ja noch eingesetzt werden umgesetzt
werden wie sich das dann auswirkt auf
eine reduktion der neuinfizierten zahlen
dauert es eben würde auch schon aus den
anderen wellen wissen also eben etwa 14
tage zehn tage 14 tage und dann sieht
man eine trendwende bei manchen bei der
allerersten welle war es ja sogar so
dann kam das etwas früher weil sich die
menschen eben einfach schon vorsichtig
verhalten haben das sehen wir aber jetzt
eben leider gar nicht also die kontakte
sind sehr groß die mobilitäts zahlen
sind auch hoch und alles das leistet
eben der virus weiterverbreitung
vorschub und wir haben mittlerweile
einen so hohen infektionsdruck das eben
auch schon leichte defizite in der
immunabwehr also bei nachlassendem
impfschutz eben auch schon eben dazu
führen dass das virus dort eindringen
kann also bei den vollständig geimpften
so dass die busse impfungen auch noch
ganz wichtig sind dass wir die möglichst
schnell vervollständigen das soll ja
dann auch passieren können wir gleich
noch dazu wie das funktionieren kann
gucken wir mal eben nach spanien herr
schaaf wir haben eine impfquote von 68 5
wenn ich richtig aber heute die
vollständig geimpften in spanien ist das
alles viel höher wie wenn man von
spanien aus auf deutschland schaut
dieses land was so hoch industriell und
gut entwickelt ist mit welcher mit
ehrlichen blick schaut man denn im
moment nach deutschland mit großer
verwunderung also wenn ich mit
spanischen freunden bekannten rede dann
reiben die sie schon die augen und
fragen mich kann das alles wahr sein die
deutschen sind doch die organisations
weltmeister und auf einmal hört man von
diesem chaos von kollabierenden
gesundheitssystemen in deutschland also
das ist sehr schwer aus spanischer sicht
zu begreifen vor allen dingen stand der
deutschland am anfang der pandemie so
gut da und spanien so schlecht das war
hier in spanien ein traumatisches
erlebnis die ersten zwei drei monate und
von daher kann man überhaupt nicht
verstehen was jetzt im zweiten jahr der
pandemie sich in spanien in deutschland
abspielen okay wie spanien was spanier
besser macht darüber sprechen wir gleich
wird aber gerne erstmal herrn klug mit
in die diskussion nehmen herr klug wir
schauen natürlich jetzt alle nach
südafrika seit dort diese variante
omikron entdeckt worden ist wie ist die
situation im moment bei ihnen wie stark
ist das ist dieses virus jetzt gerade
verbreitet
also ich glaube dass die große aufregung
hier in südafrika die ist dass die
südafrikaner sich darüber sehr aufregend
dass es diese reisebeschränkungen gibt
denn sie sagen dass man über dieses
virus über diese mutation omikron noch
viel zu wenig weiß und dass deswegen die
entscheidungen die reisebeschränkungen
einzuführen viel zu früh gefallen ist
hirnlos hat gestern einer uns in die
kamera gesagt vollkommene überreaktion
was die mutation selber betrifft sind
die südafrikaner eher gelassen sie sagen
weil sie ihren biologen glauben und die
sind ja auch sehr gut diese biologen in
diesem lande hier dass man eben noch
viel zu wenig weiß man weiß das virus
ist hoch ansteckend die mutation ist
hoch ansteckend aber bis jetzt
jedenfalls sind die symptome viel
geringer im alltäglichen leben hat sich
hier seitdem omikron bekannt ist gar
nichts geändert außer eben die aufregung
über die reisebeschränkungen
hier sind die leute weiterhin entweder
sehr diszipliniert was in vielen
stadtvierteln in vielen städten in
vielen regionen auch tatsächlich so
eingehalten wird masken pflicht soziale
distanz und so weiter und so weiter in
den armenvierteln in den townships ist
das ganz anders da wird fast nicht
eingehalten aber da hat sich seit
freitag oder auch seit donnerstag seit
dem soeben bekannt wurde eigentlich hier
gar nichts geändert okay dass er
natürlich mit erstaunen herr ulrich dass
ich da eigentlich nichts geändert hier
sind viele beunruhigte jetzt auch das
weil diese mutationen die variante ist
jetzt ja auch bei uns sind schon
nachgewiesen also wie gefährlich ist das
hier für deutschland also zunächst mal
also aufhalten werden weil die nicht
können das ist jetzt also schon
eingeschleppt nach europa wir haben
einige fälle die er schon gut
dokumentiert sind bei anderen ist es so
dass das alles noch untersucht wird
untersuchen doch nicht jeden fall immer
nur so stichprobenartig und das wird
dann muss ja auch noch sequenziert
werden dass man wirklich feststellen
kann handelt es sich jetzt um diese
variante ja oder nein und wir haben das
ja erlebt dass eine variante nämlich die
delta variante den ganzen laden
übernehmen konnte und dann die anderen
alle verdrängt hat aber wir haben es
eben auch gesehen dass andere varianten
also beispielsweise die lambda variante
oder die mini variante die in peru und
doch woanders in lateinamerika
aufgetreten sind das die zwar lokale
ausbrüche gemacht haben also auch mit
einer besseren ansteckungsfähigkeit aber
dann ist eben nicht geschafft haben sich
weltweit zu verbreiten diese beta
variante ist ja schon sehr fit also in
vielen beziehungen also was die
ansteckungsfähigkeit angeht aber eben
auch dann die wahrscheinlichkeit dass
man dann krank wird auch altersabhängig
und jetzt muss man sich eben wie gesagt
sehr genau angucken wie das ganze weiter
geht also es kann sein dass das eben
eine episode bleibt und dann wieder
verschwindet oder eben nur so eine
fußnote dann sein wird oder aber weil
das ja tatsächlich auch sehr viel fitter
geworden ist mit starken veränderungen
an dem spot protein was die
ansteckungsfähigkeit angeht also die
infektion kann leichter ausgelöst werden
das dann eben diese
bessere infektions fähigkeit dass das
daneben möglicherweise zu einer
verdrängung dann führt von delta und da
müssen wir eben dann genau die anderen
eigenschaften auch noch abklopfen also
wie hoch ist das risiko das ist eine
infektion auch eine erkrankung erfolgt
wie ist diese erkrankung denn eigentlich
gestaltet wir haben jetzt gerade ja
schon die ersten klinischen daten aus
südafrika das ist also nicht ganz so
schlimm wie eben schwerer kuppelei jeden
fall auf mit delta und dann noch die
letzte frage ist dann eben auch wie gut
decken die bereits bereits zugelassenen
impfstoffe das ganze noch mit ab es wird
aber gerade untersucht das wird oder so
da brauchen wir noch ein bisschen geduld
auch da brauchen wir geduld vorhalt was
wie ist ihr eindruck wenn man sagt ja
also welche beunruhigung ist dadurch
dieses durch diese neue mutationen
angekommen auch in der politik ist das
so ein punkt wo man gedacht jetzt muss
man noch mal extra tempo machen
also ich finde etwas bei jeder
mutationen die sich rasend schnell
verbreitet alarm angesagt ist und ich
verstehe die südafrikanische regierung
dass sie angesichts der wirtschaftlich
schwierigen lage jetzt natürlich nicht
möchte dass der tourismus in der
hauptsaison eingeschränkt wird aber auf
der anderen seite ist alle geben dazu
dass wir noch ganz wenig darüber wissen
und besser wir sagen in sag mal vier
oder sechs wochen es ist nicht so
schlimm und wir können diese
beschränkung wieder aufheben als wir
sagen in vier bis sechs wochen us doch
tödlicher als gedacht oder schädlicher
als delta und dann ist es aber hier
schon überall verbreitet also ich glaube
aber gleichzeitig dass wir aufpassen
müssen dass südafrika jetzt nicht dafür
bestraft wird dass sie da ganz
transparent diese information
kommuniziert haben und dass man da eben
auch über andere maßnahmen
nachdenken muss ich glaube die große
gefahr die wir haben ist das wenn wir
ein hohes infektionsgeschehen haben aber
das können sie besser beurteilen dass
das virus daneben fröhlich mutieren kann
und wir gefahr laufen eine variante zu
haben die die immunabwehr komplett
umgehen kann und die eben noch viel
tödlicher ist und wenn wir das wenn das
passiert dann sie zu uns alle sehr
schlechter also umso wichtiger ist doch
dann das im von harrys auch hilft das
dann auch wenn man nicht genau weiß ob
unser impfstoff dagegen hilft
selbstverständlich also das ist gar kein
argument also dass wir es eine neue
variante haben nämlich auch nikon dass
man jetzt also erst abwarten sollte dass
der impfstoff an gemacht wird oder so
das ist wohl auch gar nicht notwendig
und man sollte auf jeden fall den
eigenen immunschutz vervollständigen mit
der booster impfung dann hat man nämlich
auch viel bessere karten als das wenn
das nicht der fall wäre gegen eine
möglicherweise eben nochmal aggressivere
variante wir wissen es ja wie gesagt
noch nicht ganz genau aber
insgesamt gilt natürlich auch wir müssen
besser werden in der ihm in der
abdeckung in unserer bevölkerung also
und die noch nicht geimpften eben auch
impfen damit eben hier eine
grundimmunisierung in die bevölkerung
kommt und die hilft mit den vorhandenen
impfstoffen auch gegen eine solche neue
variante aber wo sie es gerade schon
angesprochen haben in südafrika ist noch
nicht so wahnsinnig viel geimpft worden
weil da nicht so viel impfstoff zur
verfügung steht ja fragen wir mal ein
kluger klug ist dann ist das jetzt eine
reaktion auf das auf diese entdecken
dass man sagt jetzt müssen wir noch mal
wirklich tempo machen beim impfen weil
die impfquote ist nicht besonders hoch
in südafrika
das stimmt ich würde gerne ganz kurz
noch etwas dazu sagen dass sie eben
gesagt wurde sie dafür kann nicht
bestraft werden soll südafrika ist schon
bestraft worden und zwar durch diese
reisebeschränkungen der staatspräsident
drama pause hat vorgestern in einer rede
an die nation gesagt das einzige was die
reisebeschränkungen bewirken werden ist
dass die wirtschaft in südafrika
weiterhin leidet sie ist er ohnehin
schon am anschlag und dass die
reisebeschränkungen auch gewirkt werden
dass wir dafür kann sich von dieser
pandemie sehr viel langsamer erholen
wird was man es eigentlich erhofft hat
jetzt den impfungen es ist in der tat so
dass die impfquote bei etwa 35 prozent
nur liegt wenn man an die erwachsene
bevölkerung denkt also alle ab 18 jahren
wenn man auch diejenigen die geimpft
werden könnten nämlich die ab 12
jährigen mieter zunimmt sinkt die
impfquote auf 24 prozent das ist bei
weitem nicht genug impfstoffe übrigens
sind genug im land seit geraumer zeit an
einigen monaten diese schwierigkeiten
die südafrika anfangs hatte dass man
nämlich zuerst den falschen impfstoff
besorgt hat den mann dann doch tests da
hat man herausgefunden dass das
überhaupt nichts wirkt gegen die damals
vorherrschende variante dann hat man den
in andere afrikanische länder
verkauft und auch verschenkt und dann
wurden eben andere impfstoffe
angeschafft seit mai sagen wir mal juni
juli gibt es genug impfstoffe hier im
land aber die impfbereitschaft ist nicht
sehr groß und die ist deswegen nicht
sehr groß weil es hier genau solche
vorbehalte gibt wie das angeblich die in
stoffe mehr der gesundheit schaden als
nützen das wird hier nicht so laut das
wird hier nicht so offen gesagt wie in
deutschland es gibt keine aggressiven
quer denke die in die öffentlichkeit
gehen und es gibt vor allem leider in
den armenvierteln in den townships sehr
viele verschwörungstheorien da gibt es
verschwörungstheorien die besagen diese
krankheit gibt es eigentlich gar nicht
und wenn es sie gibt ist sie nur von den
machthabenden von den wohlhabenden
erfunden worden um uns arme schwarze
weiterhin in der armut zu halten gegen
diese verschwörungstheorien kommt man
nicht an ich habe mit so vielen mit
hunderten von
geredet keine chance diese gedanken aus
den köpfen zu bekommen ich glaube dass
dahinter vor allem ein ganz ganz großes
misstrauen gegenüber den regierenden
steckt denn so wenig dass wir dafür
keinen letzten jahren regiert wurde mit
all der misswirtschaft mit der
korruption die menschen glauben den
machthabern nicht mehr und hier hilft
nur der staat hier gibt es nur
staatliche impfzentren und die leute
sagen alles was vom staat kommt lehnen
wir ab und ich glaube dass das daran
liegt dass die impfquote hier noch so
niedrig ist und das team stellt wo auch
weiterhin schleppend weiterhin schleppen
ist herr schaaf in spanien ist es ganz
anders da gibt es eine hohe impfquote
ohne hohe impfbereitschaft erklären sie
uns warum die spanier so viel eher
bereit sind sich impfen zu lassen als
die südafrikaner und die auch die
deutschen und das einige deutsche da
gibt es eine ganze reihe von gründen ich
habe eine neben schon genannt das war
der anfang der pandemie hier in spanien
er war absolut traumatisch gewesen da
hat sich das virus gerade hier in der
hauptstadt madrid rasend schnell
verbreitet in den altenheimen sind in
wenigen wochen monaten 20.000 menschen
gestorben
menschen die positiv getestet wurden in
den altenheimen durften nicht mehr in
die krankenhäuser überstellt werden und
sind dann eben in den altenheimen ganz
alleine gestorben also das war
traumatisch und das hat sich in die
nationale psyche der spanier eingebrannt
und wir haben viele leute gesagt als wir
das gesehen haben haben wir gesagt wenn
es denn einen impfstoff gibt dann werden
wir uns auch impfen lassen also das ist
ein ganz wichtiger grund ein anderer
wichtiger grund ist einfach dass das
spanische gesundheitssystem sehr viel
straffer sehr viel besser einfacher als
das deutsche organisiert ist die
impftermine wurden hier vom staat von
den gesundheitsbehörden an die leute per
sms per whatsapp versand da musst mal
mussten sich die leute also nicht wie in
deutschland um einen impftermin selbst
bemühen das war also wirklich sehr
einfach organisiert das hat wunderbar
funktioniert jeder hat eine digitale
gesundheitskarte jeden spanien da gibt
es eine telefonnummer seine e mail drauf
und es ist also ein kinderspiel für die
behörden die menschen zu erreichen und
ich würde jetzt noch einen letzten
dritten grund angeben denn mit dem
großen wort solidarität das ist in der
tat hier in spanien sehr viel
ausgeprägter
wir leben ja oft noch drei generationen
unter einem dach großeltern eltern und
die kinder
zu zeiten der finanzkrise war es so dass
mit der rente des großvaters oder der
großmutter eben alle drei generationen
überlebt haben und jetzt zu zeiten der
korona pandemie sagen halt viele junge
leute auch jetzt ist es unser zeichen
der solidarität die großeltern zu
schützen und wir lassen uns impfen also
hier gibt es ein ganz starkes
solidaritätsgefühl
heute schon einmal das hör eine
solidaritätsgefühl digitales
gesundheitssystem einladungen zum impfen
per sms also warum sind wir so weit
hinten
also ich glaube den wichtigsten punkt
der jetzt mehrfach angesprochen wurde
ist dass wir nicht diese traumatische
erfahrung gemacht haben weil was wir in
spanien sehen das sehen wir auch in
frankreich und wir sehen uns auch in
italien aber wir haben hunderttausend
tote reicht es nicht da fragt man sich
doch das ist doch eine so dramatische
zahl
das müsste doch eigentlich alle bewegen
nein die zahl reicht offenbar nicht und
was wir nicht hatten sind eben szenen in
den krankenhäusern und vor den
krankenhäusern wie die menschen sterben
weil sie auf den intensivstationen
keinen platz mehr bekommen haben das war
in allen genannten ländern der fall und
es war vergangene woche in frankreich
dann gilt schon länger die 2g regel da
muss man überall in jeder noch so
kleinen brasserie seinen impfpass
vorzeigen und er wird eingescannt um die
franzosen kenne ich als nation die wegen
jedem kleinen politischen unmut auf die
straße gehen das wird wirklich tadellos
akzeptiert deswegen verstehe ich
überhaupt nicht warum diese regeln nicht
dort wo sie schon angeordnet wurde
konsequent in deutschland durchgesetzt
wird und das zweite problem was wir
momentan haben und das darf man nicht
unterschätzen
ich glaube nicht dass eine frage der
solidarität ist weil zu beginn der
partie haben wir eine wahnsinnige
solidarität in deutschland erlebt wir
haben momentan einfach keine klare
entschiedene führung sondern wir
befinden uns in so einem vakuum wo die
alte regierung sagt ja wir sind ja
eigentlich nicht mehr im amt und alles
was wir gemacht haben war tipptopp und
die neue regierung sagt ja wir wollen
uns von eurer politik absetzen und
eigentlich sind wir auch noch gar nicht
in der verantwortung
und man muss sagen das ist für eine
situation wie die pandemie ist das eine
toxische mischung und wem lassen sie das
an also ja es hat ja mal gesagt der
führung will oder bestellt der kriegt
sie auch und damit ist ja mal hat er
immer werbung für sich gemacht warum
nimmt er nicht klar dass das heft des
handelns in die hand also ich würde es
inzwischen gar niemanden mehr an lassen
weil ich finde man muss dieses der es
verantwortlich diesem verantwortlich die
länder noch nicht genug egal ich finde
jetzt ist natürlich herr scholz und die
neue regierung gefragt weil die werden
uns jetzt künftig regieren jetzt müssen
sie da mutig maßen haben treffe sie
müssen meines erachtens harte maßnahmen
treffen kurzzeitige maßnahmen und dann
müssen sie sozusagen die auswerten und
dann entscheiden wie es weiter geht und
nicht immer diese kleinen schritte wir
haben vorhin schon darüber gesprochen
und dann mal gucken diese halbherzigen
maßnahmen die werden uns ewig in dieser
situation halten und dann wird auch die
bevölkerung immer weniger bereit seien
mitzumachen angekündigt ist jetzt ja
auch eine impfpflicht oder die müsste
dann im bundestag geschlossen werden da
soll der fraktionszwang aufgehoben
werden jetzt fragt man sich ja es gibt
jetzt heute auch die regelung dass im
einzelhandel soll dann sollen dann
ungeimpfte eigentlich nur noch in die
läden des täglichen bedarf sonst soll
einzelhandel führt auf 10 192 g
gelten ist das was wo sie das gefühl
haben da geht es wirklich also ist der
einzelhandel wirklich ein treiber geht
es darum infektionen zu vermeiden oder
geht es doch eher darum dann menschen zu
überzeugen dass sie sich impfen lassen
sollen naja also beides wahrscheinlich
also wir haben natürlich immer kontakte
in innenräumen ist das jetzt besonders
besonders risikoreich weil man ja dann
also auch
kleinere lufträume hat wo dann die
aerosole sich darin aufhalten können das
haben wir alles schon gelernt in den
vergangenen
wellen und jetzt ist es eben besonders
kritisch weil wir eben sehr sehr viele
viren gerade zirkulieren haben weil wir
eben ist so lange haben so lange
versäumt haben dass also die maßnahmen
rechtzeitig eingesetzt wurden ob das
dann ausreicht dass wir dann diese
sachen also diese einzelhandelsbereich
oder eben auch andere zusammentreffen
dann eben auf zweig oder zweig plus
beschränken das müssen wir erst noch
sehen ich fürchte nur dass wir eben noch
weiterhin eben diese kontakte reduzieren
müssen also beispielsweise
großveranstaltungen wie fußballspiele
das können wir uns jetzt in dieser
situation wirklich nicht leisten denn
das treibt natürlich die büros
weiterverbreitung noch an und auch wenn
das unter 2 gegen regeln stattfindet
kann es eben immer noch dazu kommen weil
eben der immunschutz ja auch langsam
über die monate etwas nachlässt und der
infektionsdruck ist so groß dass das
virus dann eben gnadenlos ausnutzt und
wir haben einfach nicht mehr die zeit
dass wir das noch ausprobieren könnten
ja wir hätten auch selbst das wochenende
vielleicht schon den fuß absagen können
dass wir eine tolle idee gewesen also
das ist aber also nicht absagen
vielleicht hat er soeben ohne ohne
zuschauer in den stadien er denn das ist
ja nicht nur im stadion an das problem
sondern eben auch noch beim weg rein und
wieder raus oder dann in den
öffentlichen verkehrsmitteln alle diese
dinge wo die menschen dann sehr sehr eng
zusammen sind da kann das eben passieren
und es passiert und das passiert eben
leider auch unter den vollständig
geimpften deswegen sind wir jetzt auch
durch diese virtuelle eben besonders
gezwungen diese booster impfung und
möglichst flächendeckend einzuführen und
wäre es denn dann trotzdem sinnvoll
jetzt zu sagen weil sie sagen da lässt
der infektionsschutz nach es wäre dann
doch sinnvoller zu sagen ja auch für
geimpfte ein loch da ja möglicherweise
abgestuft aber eben auch mit kontakt
reduktionen also es gab ja schon jetzt
auch die appelle schon vorher also auch
von unserer bundespräsidenten dass man
freiwillig die kontakte etwas reduziert
das galt dann für alle und gilt für alle
dass das damit tragen wir alle dann dazu
bei dass er jetzt diese welle brechen
dass wir wieder langsam runter kommen
von diesen zahlen und erst zeitversetzt
wird das dann eine entlastende wirkung
haben auf unsere krankenhäuser und vor
allen dingen auf die intensivstation
also wir müssen jetzt noch sehen wie wir
die mit den kapazitäten noch aushalten
können und da werden ja schon intensiv
patienten verlegt durch die luftwaffe
das ist ja schon schlimm genug ja herr
schaaf wie bereitet man sich dann in
spanien auf dieses neue virus die
virusvariante vor in spanien hatte man
ja auch einen viel härteren lockdown als
in deutschland sie hat unglaublich viel
geringeren radius wo sie das haus
verlassen durften also gibt es da jetzt
wieder ideen dass man aus sagt okay wir
müssen obwohl wir so viel wie impfte
haben vielleicht trotzdem noch mal
strenger werden jetzt
das gibt es zum teil ich will jetzt auch
kein zu rosiges bild von der spanischen
politik zeichnen die ist auch ziemlich
toxisch und sehr polarisiert auch zum
anfang der pandemie sprach die
konservative opposition von den toten
von ministerpräsidenten sanchez also da
ist nun auch nicht sehr liebevoll
miteinander umgegangen
derzeit ist es so dass einige der
autonomen regionen die einführung des
passes planen also quasi die 2g regel
für den besuch von bars von restaurants
und von fitnesscentern aber das ist eben
nur in einigen regionen hier in der
hauptstadt madrid hier regiert eine
konservative regierung die haben
eigentlich überhaupt keine
beschränkungen außer der masken pflicht
in innenräumen also wenn man hier durch
madrid am abend geht könnte man denken
corona hat es nie gegeben wenn man nicht
die masken sehen wurde also wir haben
hier auch einen flickenteppich von
föderalen unterschieden aber man will
eben jetzt in doch vielen regionen die
2g regel in hinblick auf die
weihnachtstage jetzt hier einführen
erhoffter wenn man hier jetzt
flächendeckend zweig einführt dann sagen
natürlich einige die das eine ungeimpfte
fühlen sich dann extrem eingeschränkt
fühlen sich in ihren freiheiten bedrängt
wenn sie gerade eine gegend wohnen wo
die inzidenz nicht hoch ist ist das
gerecht und was womit muss man dann
rechnen mit welchen protesten also ich
glaube dass zweig
alternativlos ist angesichts der hohen
zahl an neuinfektionen die es wurde ja
auch schon erwähnt auch schon jetzt dazu
führt dass die intensivstation teilweise
überlastet sind und in so einer
situation ist es natürlich ein absoluter
ja fast naiver irrglaube zu denken man
wäre so auf einer insel der seligen oder
einem gebiet der seligen also
weihnachten steht vor der tür da werden
die leute wieder hin und her reisen und
selbst wenn ein bundesland hohe
niedriger instanz zahl hat dann ist es
am ende des tages genauso gefährdet
abgesehen davon dass keines mehr
wirklich niedrigen zins zahlen hat ok
also das sagen sie das muss man
aushalten auch als gesellschaft absolut
als auch wenn man jetzt sagen würde man
macht die weihnachtsmänner kein
fußballspiel weihnachtsmärkte dicht und
dann kein guter start für die ampel
koalition oder schwieriger start ich
glaube vor allem dass wir diesen
spielraum um solche maßnahmen zu testen
diese niedrigschwelligen maßnahmen zu
testen dass wir den eben momentan nicht
mehr haben den können wir dann
vielleicht im frühjahr wieder haben in
die situation wieder besser ist und dann
kann man sagen man probiert in
bestimmten regionen aus aber momentan
geht es noch darum diese holen incidents
zahlen insgesamt runterzubringen sie es
wie viel vertrauen haben sie noch in die
politik weil die wissenschaft hat so
extrem gefahren und sie laufen da so ein
bisschen gerade im moment in diesem also
in dieser übergangsphase von der eine
regierung zu anderen kommen sie ja nicht
wirklich weiter es dauert alles länger
diese vertrauen haben sie dennoch dass
das was wo sie vor vor den sie waren das
was dann wirklich ernst genommen und
gehört wird ja vertrauen würde ich nicht
denn hoffnung vielleicht eher und es ist
leider so gewesen über den wahlkampf und
auch über diese ganze zeit wo jetzt eben
noch mit den koalitionsverhandlungen
dann andere themen im vordergrund
standen haben wir eben wertvolle zeit
verschenkt und es hat sich niemand so
richtig getraut dann das ein unterschied
gemacht werden muss zwischen den
ungeimpften und den geimpften und jetzt
sehen wir dass es leider schon so
schlimm geworden ist dass jetzt auch die
vollständig geimpften die ja alles
richtig gemacht haben jetzt ebenfalls
mit einbußen in
freiheitsgraden sozusagen rechnen müssen
und und wir müssen uns noch mal völlig
klar machen wir sind in dieser schlimmen
lage wegen der vielen menschen die sich
in deutschland nicht haben impfen lassen
wenn wir solche situationen hätten wie
in spanien und frankreich
dann hätten wir jetzt zwar auch eine
virtuelle aber die wäre eben ganz
einfach zu handhaben gewesen wie das in
spanien ja auch der fall ist das ist
etwas was wir jetzt hier irgendwie
bewältigen müssen und dazu müssen wir
jetzt also eben auch diese entschiedenen
maßnahmen jetzt sofort treffen und ich
hoffe dass also diese bund länder
sitzung heute und dann auch noch am
donnerstag dann auch wirklich diese
maßnahmen beschließen wird das ganze
einsetzen wird und das dann sukzessive
auch die impfpflicht kommen wird
zuallererst in dem im gesundheitsbereich
denn es ist überhaupt nicht einzusehen
dass jemand um geimpftes mit patienten
zu tun hat das ist ungefähr so wie wenn
ein chirurg in den operationssaal geht
und wäscht sich nicht die hände das
heißt also das ist einfach das gehört
dazu und das muss dann eben eine große
aber damit wäre man doch wäre es
ehrlicher gewesen viel für eine
wirkliche im pflicht einzuführen weil
wenn die jetzt kommen soll wird sie ja
wahrscheinlich dann erst im februar oder
zu greifen ja das immer auszuschließen
das war eben diese dieser heißen
diskussion geschuldet die dann eben
diese impfgegner da ja auch mit
angefeuert haben und vielleicht war es
eben auch in dieser phase wo wir noch
relative ruhe hatten so richtung sommer
auch versäumt worden noch mal
entschieden da auch argumentativ gegen
diese krone leugner und gegner
vorzugehen um das wirklich noch mal ganz
klar ein plastisch zu machen dass er es
einfach kein haltbarer wissenschaftlich
haltbarer standpunkt ist und in den
talkshows wurde das ja auch immer wieder
mal thematisiert aber immer so dass es
irgendwie dann am ende so dahinter ist
der eindruck entstanden ist ja das ist
auch ein möglicher standpunkt aber das
ist es eben leider nicht sondern es ist
einfach so dass eben alle diese
argumente gegen das impfen und gegen das
impfen speziell jetzt in dieser corona
pandemie dass diese argumente alle
widerlegbar sind und das übrig bleibt
wir müssen impfen anders kommen wir aus
dieser pandemie nun mal nicht raus wir
können nicht einfach abwarten und uns
weiter testen das ist verlängert das
ganze nur und jetzt müssen wir eben
sehen dass wir diese durchseuchung wie
wir gerade erleben bei den ungeimpften
dass wir die möglichst strecken
wenn sie sich schon nicht impfen lassen
damit sie nicht alle auf einmal in unser
gesundheitssystem reingehen ich würde
gern nach südafrika ging herr klug wir
haben jetzt gerade gehört der euro ist
natürlich etwas frustriert über die art
wie mit der wissenschaft mit den
wissenschaftlichen erkenntnissen
umgegangen wird wie ist es in südafrika
hört man da auf die wissenschaftler
welche welche position hat die da und
wer ist sozusagen der der top corona
manager in ihrem land
da gibt es viele und in der tat die
bevölkerung so sehr sie auch der
regierung und auch den behörden
misstraut so sehr vertrauen sie den
wissenschaftlern hier die haben einen
exzellenten ruf nicht nur hier im land
übrigens sondern weltweit die
südafrikanischen laboren und die
südafrikanischen wissenschaftler gehört
zu den führenden laboren was
infektionskrankheiten betrifft überhaupt
da gibt es einige labore hier in
johannesburg
diejenigen die das omikron die auch die
omikron variante jetzt entdeckt haben
ist ein labor in durban der stadt am
indischen ozean
das heißt christ das gehört zur
universität von durban die haben früher
schon andere varianten entdeckt die sind
einfach exzellent und auf diese menschen
hören die südafrikaner sehr wohl
und wie sehr ist man abhängig von also
von der menge des impfstoffes jahren
eben gut dass die impfquote ist noch
nicht so hoch haben sie genug genug
impfstoff
ja in südafrika gibt es genug impfstoffe
das ist seit mai juni ungefähr gibt es
genug im stoffe aber dienstbereitschaft
ist halt so gering ich habe mit so
vielen leuten gesprochen in den letzten
wochen und monaten die mir gesagt haben
corona ist für uns nur noch eine sorge
mehr sie ist nicht das große thema das
alle anderen themen platt macht die
einzige die richtige pandemie sagen mir
viele südafrikaner ist die armut die
richtige pandemie ist die
arbeitslosigkeit heute sind die neuen
arbeitslosigkeit und zahlen
herausgekommen 35 prozent der menschen
in südafrika sind offiziell arbeitslos
66 prozent der jugend sind arbeitslos
und das sind nur die offiziellen zahlen
die offiziellen zahlen gehen davon aus
dass zum beispiel die
jugendarbeitslosigkeit der 80 prozent
liegt darauf schauen die menschen da
wollen sie dass sich was ändert und die
menschen sagen corona ist nur noch ein
das wird sich jetzt ein bisschen komisch
an aber das sagen wir wirklich corona
ist nur noch ein grund mehr warum ich
eventuell früher sterben ich möchte hier
ein menschenwürdiges leben führen ganz
egal wie lange es ist aber krone trägt
natürlich dann bei zur schlechteren
wirtschaftlichen entwicklung wodurch es
dann wenn den menschen noch schlechter
geht
ja das natürlich schon aber das glauben
die menschen nicht weil eben das
misstrauen gegenüber der regierung so
groß ist sie sagen in den letzten zehn
elf jahren habt ihr die regierenden
unser land so wirtschaftlich in grund
und boden gebohrt macht endlich mal was
die misswirtschaft ist wirklich
unglaublich in manchen provinzen
funktioniert kein gemeinwesen keine
müllabfuhr keine wasserversorgung keine
stromversorgung und darauf schauen die
menschen und sie schon nicht so sehr auf
corona deswegen habe ich ja gerade
gesagt corona ist nicht so dass große
alles bestimmende thema in südafrika
wenn ich mir die medien angucke selbst
omikron war nur eine kurze zeit
aufmacher thema nummer eins das was
wirklich das große thema es ist
armutsbekämpfung
arbeitslosigkeit bekämpfung bekämpfung
der misswirtschaft bekämpfung der
korruption
das sind die großen themen in südafrika
und corona kommt nur noch von top so zu
sagen okay das ist interessant zu hören
ist bei uns natürlich wirklich jetzt
ganz anders frau deutschland was
erwarten sie denn jetzt konkret von
donnerstag von diesem treffen und über
das so ein punkt sein wo man dann ja
sich auch traut auch indem man sagt man
macht im bundestag diskutiert man über
diese impfpflicht wo man auch er traut
das sozusagen es vielleicht noch einen
größeren aufschrei von der gruppe gibt
von den impfgegnern zum beispiel man das
aushält den kritikern und auch von
kritikern der kontakt beschränkungen
also ich erwarte von donnerstag dass die
maßnahmen auf die man sich heute ja
quasi schon verständigt hat dass die
quasi zu papier gebracht und auch zügig
durchgesetzt werden und natürlich wird
die impfpflicht erstmal für
verwerfungen sorgen die ja dann aber
auch erst im nächsten frühjahr kommen
würde und ich glaube je weiter die
situation
voranschreitet mit den dramatischen
zahlen und auch mit den bildern die
jetzt immer mehr kommen werden und den
berichten dass angehörige
schwierigkeiten hatten ihre erkrankten
angehörigen versorgt zu bekommen dass da
der widerstand
zurückgehen wird ich glaube aber auch
ein thema was wir jetzt noch gar nicht
gesprochen hatten aber was jetzt auch
immer mehr beschäftigen wird auch jetzt
schon beschäftigt ist dass wir mit
diesem pflegekraft mangel dass da auch
die neue regierung jetzt endlich wege
finden muss wie sie den beheben will
weil zu dieser sehr verschärften
situation hat er nicht so sehr der abbau
der intensivbetten beigetragen wie immer
behauptet wird sondern die tatsache dass
beim pflegepersonal eben viele einfach
nicht mehr gekonnt haben und
rausgegangen sind aus dem job wie sieht
die situation da in spanien und auch in
portugal sind ja auch für portugal
zuständig wie sieht die dort aus also
gibt es in den krankenhäusern gibt es da
genügend personal kann man da noch
menschen anwerben sind sie noch bereit
diesen beruf auszuüben
die situation derzeit ist eben relativ
entspannt aufgrund der hohen impfquoten
die hospitalisierung rate und die
belegung auf den intensivstationen hier
in spanien liegt bei gerade sieben
prozent vor einem jahr zu weihnachten
vor weihnachten 2020 lag sie bei 27
prozent also die situation hat sich
schon sehr entspannt aber man muss auch
sagen spanien und vor allen dingen auch
portugal haben sehr viel weniger
intensivbetten als deutschland auch
deswegen hat man jetzt sehr verwundert
von hier aus auf die lage in deutschland
geschaut man hat immer gedacht die
deutschen sind doch bestens ausgestattet
da gibt es keine engpässe
und jetzt stellt man eben fest das
gegenteil ist der fall hier in spanien
und auch in portugal ist die lage
derzeit relativ
ruhig aber auch die regierung in
portugal hat deswegen
jetzt auch angekündigt man will in der
ersten januarwoche einen teilweisen
lockdown noch einmal verhängen in bars
und restaurants und homeoffice anordnen
weil man eben noch mal so chaotische und
schlimme verhältnisse wie im letzten
weihnachten 2020 verhindern will denn da
ist ja portugal gewissermaßen kollabiert
und wir erinnern uns die deutsche
bundeswehr ist er dann auch nach
lissabon geflogen um auszuhelfen also
das portugiesische gesundheitssystem ist
wirklich auf kante genäht und kann sich
so eine wiederholung einer solch
extremen situation nicht mehr erlauben
wo ich sie haben ja schon angesprochen
dass die luftwaffe jetzt hilft patienten
von bayern nach in nordrhein-westfalen
gab wieder nach deutschland zu
transportieren jetzt soll es ja einen
krisenstab geben der geführt wird von
general breuer ist dass der chef des
kommandos territorial kräfte hat große
erfahrungen organisation war auch in der
art katastrophe tätig wie sehr das für
uns ist das ein symbol oder ist es
wirklich also kann er etwas machen was
jetzt echt gefehlt hat einer
organisation
na ja also das waren so was hat einen
krisenstab dann auf bundesebene das ist
sicherlich sinnvoll allerdings jetzt
ihnen anzukündigen und einzusetzen das
ist für die augenblickliche lage
natürlich jetzt erstmal nicht direkt
hilfreich sondern das kann dann erst
noch kommen falls wir das eben auch
verlängert dann eben noch bearbeiten
müssen also ist hätte man das viel
früher machen müssen
ja natürlich das ist das ist wahr aber
natürlich auch muss man auch sehen dass
eben bei der alten bundesregierung ja
durchaus maßnahmen immer wieder auch
vorgeschlagen wurden auch rechtzeitig
und dann aber nur verschleppt von den
ländern dann entsprechend auch umgesetzt
worden sind es hat sehr lange gedauert
bis man bei der zweiten welle dann
wirklich in dem locker umgegangen ist
mit eben der konsequenz dass
zehntausende menschen dann in dieser
herbst wintersaison gestorben sind und
auch jetzt haben wir ja eine situation
wo wir uns auch scheinbar wohl dran
gewöhnt haben dass pro tag 200 bis 300
menschen an oder mit dem corona virus in
deutschland versterben also so viel wie
durch den flugzeugabsturz ums leben
kommen würden jeden tag und das geht
aber jetzt eben einfach so weiter und
deswegen würde man dann sagen ja wir
brauchen jetzt eben expertise vor ort
und das gut gemanagt das heißt also von
von menschen die eben wissen wie man mit
mit krisenbewältigung umgeht und wo man
dann eben auch ein gutes netzwerk hat
also von daher ist so ein krisenstab
sicherlich auf einen mehrwert erhalten
wie sehen sie es dass selbst
oder scholz hat das ja direkt ganz am
anfang also den koalitionsvertrag
vorgestellt hat er gesagt wir machen
jetzt ja so einen krisenstab aber der
arbeitet ja noch nicht also wie bewerten
sie das dass es den jetzt geben soll
also ich finde es erstmal eine
interessante personalie mit dass jetzt
ein hochrangiger militär eingesetzt wird
und wir haben in italien portugal
gesehen dass das sehr gut funktionieren
kann und der leiter der whu
notfallprogramme hat zu beginn der
pandemie mal gesagt in so einer
situation da muss man schnell handeln
weil wenn man lange überlegt dann macht
man die situation nicht besser und ich
glaube was man beim militär lernt ist
dass man in einer krisensituation
schnell handelt aber natürlich für die
aktuelle situation
das haben sie erwähnt bringt es jetzt
noch nichts und deswegen muss man jetzt
andere maßnahmen finden die jetzt also
besser gestern als heute umgesetzt
werden die kontakte müssen 70 bis 80
prozent beschränkt werden zurückgefahren
werden wenn wir das infektionsgeschehen
eindämmen wollen aber wie wichtig ist es
das so zu sagen dass man das so eine
person gibt wo man das gefühl hat die
nach letztes jetzt durch das wichtig
war das vorher sparen war das kaiser
brachte immer gewarnt hat also als wir
haben auch wir wissen noch nicht wer
gesundheitsminister wird
ich finde dass angela merkel schon
relativ klar gemacht hat dass sie da
jetzt auch mutig vorangehen will und ja
von anfang an da
alarm geschlagen hat ansonsten muss man
natürlich sagen so eine person das ist
vor allem eine symbolik das ist aber
kann aber auch total wichtig seien und
wie wichtig ist es dass wir bald müssen
oder wie schwierig ist es dass wir erst
am vierten dezember wissen wer der neue
gesundheitsminister dieses und hat mich
ehrlich gesagt inakzeptabel also ich
meine man kann doch aus dem posten deren
leben also der in der jetzigen situation
muss man sagen neben dem bundeskanzler
der wichtigste posten ist in der
aktuellen situation den kann man doch
nicht zusammen strategischen spiel
machen ich meine und was ist in zwei
wochen anders um diese entscheidung zu
treffen und wenn herr scholz herrn
lauterbach nicht möchte dass dann muss
man ihm zugestehen
aber dann soll er doch bin ich jetzt
jemanden vorschlagen die auch jetzt
eingebunden werden kann und der dann in
regierungsverantwortung die
gesundheitspolitik managt also auch da
gilt je eher desto besser hätten wir
gerne in lauterbach als gesundheit ja
eigentlich schon also er ist ja sehr
versiert kennt sich aus ist wir kennen
eben mit dieser personen wofür er steht
und was er für kompetenzen hat die ja
unter beweis gestellt hat also das wäre
in der augenblicklichen lage eine sehr
gute besetzung und ich denke dass herr
lauterbach auch noch mehr kann als
epidemiologie und panini sondern eben
auch noch die entsprechenden
reformbedarf in unserem gesundheitswesen
entsprechend angehen und von daher würde
ich das für eine sehr gute besetzung
halten wir schaffen mit was rechnen sie
für dieses weihnachten ja für spanien
für portugal mit welchen blick schaut
man darauf also wird man familienfeiern
plan machen also mit welchem gefühl geht
man in ihren ländern dort in das
weihnachtsfest
also man geht nicht ganz entspannt in
dieser situation aber glaube ich mit
einem doch sehr anderen gefühl als bei
ihnen in deutschland also wenn ich hier
durch madrid am abend gehe ist fast die
korona pandemie beendet bis eben auf die
besagten masken aber die regierung ist
schon sehr vorsichtig und es werden halt
maßnahmen wie die 2g regel jetzt
eingeführt man will einfach nicht noch
mal ein weihnachten wie vor einem jahr
erleben als die gesundheitssysteme in
spanien und auch in portugal sehr unter
anspannung standen gern dann ganz kurz
noch zu ihnen herr klug mit welchem
gefühl schaut man bei ihnen auf dieses
gen jahreswechsel
ich glaube wir schauen noch gar nicht
soweit wir schauen noch nicht bis nach
weihnachten wir schauen noch nicht was
ist nach silvester oder neujahr wir
schauen jetzt auf das ende dieser woche
virologen haben gestern angekündigt es
wird eine vervierfachung der
neuinfektionen geben wenn das der fall
ist dann wird die regierung obwohl sie
es eigentlich nicht will um einen
weiteren lockdown nicht herumkommen aber
weihnachten ist noch so weit weg aus
südafrikanischer sicht da kann wirklich
noch sehr sehr viel passieren da ist
noch viel bewegung drin okay ganz
herzlichen dank herr schaaf herr klug
verholfen und herr ulrich für die
diskussion hier im studio vielen dank
fürs interesse es wird sicherlich nicht
die letzte corona sendung gewesen seien
leider muss man ja dazu sagen morgen
schauen wir aber mal auch die cdu denn
die drei kandidaten für den vorsitz
stellen sich am morgen der gemeinsamen
diskussion können sie bei phönix seen
und danach anschließend diskutieren wir
hier in der phoenix runde wer denn wohl
der beste vorsitzende für die cdu sein
könnte bis dahin tschüss
[Musik]